so chris you know the other chris keeps
telling me that this is supposedly the
hardest push-up in the world so let's
[Music]
see oh
i cannot believe how hard this is
hey what's up chris what's on your mind
thank you for joining me here today i've
got a little surprise for you is it a
challenge
what do i give off like a challengey
vibe that i'm just like constantly when
it says you're recording the call i i
imagine it's going to be for a video so
i'd rather not even tell you i think i
should just show you okay i want to see
if this is possible it better not oh man
it's a fitness challenge
dude this guy's arms are bigger than my
legs he's a monster he's giving off
those uh geodude from pokemon vibes
just solid rock us a push-up it's not
just any push-up all right so he's
flipping his hands inward you go wide
and you push oh that's it wait what wait
so he just he just went straight up to
stand up so he's in a push-up position
and then explodes into a standing
position in one movement i feel like i
just want to see someone try so uh
you're it okay um i'll give it a try but
you have to do it with me fine we'll
both try this what is this the
impossible tick-tock push-up virtual
handshake deal oh man let's go let's do
this
it's really frustrating because the more
you try to do this theoretically the
more tired your body and your muscles
become decreasing your chances of
getting it so i think a lot of this is
just going to be practicing technique
and then trying to nail this move within
the first five minutes of each day when
i was doing this i felt pretty good and
then i watch it back and it looks
pathetic so laying down a yoga mat to do
this safety first here i am trying to
get the internal rotation of those hands
there we go the second your hands let go
it's not even that high but your body
freaks out like you're just throwing out
the window of a skyscraper you're
fighting against thousands of years of
evolution here i'm still trying to
figure out what the benefit is of
turning your hands inward i imagine if
they're just straight up because you
kind of go in an arc there's just less
time that you're actually like touching
the ground whereas here it's at a
shorter part of the arc but it seems
like only a few inches and it's really
awkward so here's me putting my hands
out wider which feels more comfortable
for the push-up
maybe it's because i'm not warmed up
that's totally what it is right it's a
little bit excessive for a first attempt
we need to come into this guns blazing
though it just started to click that
okay i can't just push i have to push
and then drag my body up i'm impressed
off of day one well it's it's your turn
there's no time like the present i see
you got the the neon colored shorts i
think that gives you an extra 15 points
into strength i had to do it to him a
lot of what you'll see here is me like
trying to figure out how explosive my
just like push-up can be a little uh
carpet movement here we we fixed that
ultimately with the uh like-minded yoga
mat decision here i also wanted to see
how close i could get from my knees a
major disadvantage i have is being 6'4
so it feels like a whole lot of legs to
get underneath me i i'm 90 legs you get
the gist of it i thought that was pretty
good you had a really technical approach
of breaking it down step by step i think
going off the knees is a pretty good
idea so i'll try that if nothing else it
helped just for convincing your body to
like get your hands out from underneath
you like mentally committing to the
movement
i showed you mine first last time so i
think it's your turn i knew that was
coming i've got the mat out again i have
to mention that the fit is getting an
upgrade too you've got the colored
shorts the first time now you got the
sleeveless shirt next time it's a
headband i'm constantly going to talk
myself into that i need more uh drip to
make this happen uh the carpet
underneath me like started to move as i
like tried to push up
almost face panting so we're gonna roll
the rug out of the way dangerously close
to the desk though we're playing with
some sharp corners here i'm gonna be
honest trying to see how high i could
propel off the ground
that's pretty good height yeah from the
kneeling i'm just following your lead
here all right on that note show me what
you got harry i'm just stretching out
maybe that's something i also need to be
doing i'm going i mean that's just
because i'm sitting down all day so i
feel like my body is turning into the
shape of a chair
so i tried it from the knees problem is
i was wearing shorts here and when you
try to slide up with your knees the yoga
mat turns into a cheese grater and that
was not fun god oh here we go oh
that was so close so basically my
approach is whatever you got to do to
just bring your toes upward i'll bend as
much at the waist as i want i'll just
keep my legs straight right so
i'll eventually start straightening out
i was thinking way too hard and then
turns out i wasn't really putting much
effort into it i was thinking too much
so another thing that i paid attention
to was where are you trying to put your
hands you know you could kind of do a
high push-up up here or you can do it
down here i was trying to push down and
you can kind of like push like this and
like pull your legs upward i think this
was a pretty good attempt right here
very close for sure but now it's just
keep everything straight and don't think
too much i think both your feet coming
up together too is really crucial you
think less i'll think more let's do it
until next time
elish sent me a clip of him trying it if
you want to see it i absolutely want to
see it
what a starting frame oh my god
oh
not bad he got some air a hundred
percent so first thing to note i decided
to go to my small little bedroom and i
realized i sleep on a japanese futon so
i can kind of use that as a crash mat i
kind of got a little bit off the ground
i'll say a lot a bit off the ground
basically i'm just trying to catapult
myself forward and i just took the fall
like that i see with your crash mat here
getting over the fear of just failing it
i will say at least i'm feeling more
confident about it probably a lot of
that's because of the mattress i'm
impressed yet again per my previous day
i gotta get rid of any movable surface
that's gonna throw me off and then
actually did a little uh
zamboni action here to just clear the
dust because clearly the dust was what
was holding me back kind of took your
advice and have to keep escalating the
uniform here i've started trying to keep
my arms even wider with my hands still
angled in i'm pushing myself off the
ground with my arms almost letting
myself fall and letting my feet like
naturally do what they have to do if
that makes sense and you're also right
in front of walls in front of walls
we're on hard wood i'm curious if i
should just practice not even trying to
move my legs and just getting off the
ground just to see if i can push harder
and harder in that capacity and like
take it one step at a time where i'm
almost trying to assemble so many steps
at once when you're thinking about
trying to stand up or bring your legs
forward you just forget that you're
supposed to push for sure i'm assuming
at some point we're gonna have to uh
call in the expert right i think we're
gonna have to hopefully he can give us
some pointers and maybe just like
sprinkle a little uh strongman dust on
us i think that's called pre-workout is
strong
is there one like really common mistake
uh usually it's with them piking or
stepping before they actually get up
sliding forward that's not a clean rep
if you like slide forward and pipe if it
does go straight up well for that you
need a lot of explosive strength gotcha
so i think we just got to get stronger
then let me show you some of our
attempts starting from here what's the
next thing he should work on from here
oh man uh i'm just thinking about
actually getting stronger
in a push-up and many variations of it
so wide push-up narrow push-up diamond
push-up incline decline and then slowly
progressing into a explosive push-up
week by week month by month and then
you're gonna have a lot of people just
standing up and then i'm not gonna be
the only one i'm locked in this is the
pep talk i needed we just gotta get back
to work then yeah yeah
[Music]
oh
oh
[Music]
oh no
yeah you're not a straight line
i i don't want people on youtube to hate
me but like i'm not going to be able to
do this in in the confines of of this
video i'm confident that over time i
think i would be able to get this just
really trying to build up some like
explosive upper body strength i think
this is really tough because as deon was
saying the technique is very important
and the skill of doing the push-up is
really important but past a certain
point the only thing that's going to get
you there is actual explosive strength
which you can't really shortcut around
because building the muscle to do that
just takes a very long time and i think
we've hit a point where i don't know how
to predict how long it's going to take
for me to go from where i am to the
final thing so at some point we're going
to have to just call it a video we could
be doing this forever you were you're
were very generous throwing the word we
around you were very very close to
getting it i'm i'm very far but uh yeah
i don't know i don't know what's next
yeah if anyone wants to try it we'll put
the link to the tick tock down in the
description let us know how you do tag
us on instagram i guess if you put it on
your story or something like that do you
have what it takes
uh put up or shut up i didn't mean that
don't
don't shut up try the try the push-up
[Music]
you